the white house is in full damage
control after new FBI testimony poked
holes in the West wing's timeline of
events leading to Rob Porter's
resignation
FBI director Christopher Rea told
Congress that a background check of
President Trump staff secretary was
finished before Porter resigned over
allegations he abused his ex-wives White
House officials had said the background
check was still going on hours later the
White House press secretary said career
officials were aware of issues with
Porter as early as last November but
claims top advisors to the president
were not told about the severity of the
allegations until last week major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning coming apart at the
seams that is the description of the
West Wing from a top White House adviser
the reason the deepening sense among
some senior officials that even inside
the truth is not being told about the
Rob Porter situation that's creating new
divisions and a sense of mistrust
meanwhile President Trump in his public
utterances at least appears indifferent
to the underlying issue of domestic
abuse and the turmoil it's causing
inside his own White House we
administrative it closed the file in
January
FBI director Christopher Rea
contradicted White House explanations
that former staff secretary Rob Porter's
background check investigation was
incomplete the FBI followed established
protocols the White House maintains it
did not know the full extent of
allegations against Porter before the
story broke last Wednesday but according
to the FBI's timeline it submitted a
partial report in March of last year
completed its background investigation
in late July followed up with additional
information in November and closed its
file on Porter last month White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders and her
deputy Raj Shah have for days said the
opposite his background investigation
was ongoing we let the process play out
it was ongoing Sanders again amended her
story Tuesday saying the White House
personnel security office had received
information about Porter from the FBI
but had yet to make a final
recommendation to senior staff about his
security clearance the spotlight
remained on White House chief of staff
John Kelly who learned a
Porter's alleged behavior last November
but allowed him to keep his job Kelly
told the Wall Street Journal the
handling of the abuse scandal was all
done right do you believe president
Trump has repeatedly ignored
opportunities to condemn domestic
violence Iowa Republican senator Joni
Ernst said the president needs to do
more I think he needs to send a stronger
message it is important to note that
Porter has denied all of these abuse
allegations meanwhile South Carolina
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham wants
more answers from Kelly about what he
knew when and speculation continues
about possible replacements for Kelly
with Trump loyalists now mentioning top
economic advisor Gary Cohen and the head
of legislative affairs mark short Gail
and the story continues thank you very
much major